this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they get episodes
early unedited and AD free if you'd like
to support check the link in the
description yeah hi Mike welcome uh we
did just have a long chat that is not
part of the episode it happens though we
did touch a little bit on layoffs at um
epic uh which uh I was reading a
statistic that this year the amount of
layoffs it's like 8,000 jobs lost or
something like that across the games
industry like just an absurd amount of
of layoffs um again for companies that
are profitable though technically I
hesitate to say uh epic is profitable
they are year-over-year
um increasing in
value but it also depends by Department
like fortnite is profitable for sure the
engine possibly not as much I also
suspect they spent a lot of money on um
that court case do not think the Apple
court cases would have been very cheap
for them but regardless sucks um like
such
a awful series
of things to happen in an industry that
so many people are so passionate about
and I don't know just [__] bmer um
but I did also want to talk about Unity
today because we got one uh person let
go that everyone feels really positively
about one person's been made redundant
and I've not seen a lot of worry about
that and we feel great about it uh so we
had the episode with Ramy uh what three
weeks ago now talking about that the
last episode we put out I think that was
great question I don't know what time is
anymore I don't know what yeah it's been
a while I think it's been might
Starfield two weeks ago that's right
which as an upate bunch of nonsense yes
I did reach out to Bethesda and ask if
we could have somebody on the show and
they did decline uh it was like a
respectfully declined but I also like
always doubted that they would because
we'd be asking them to to ruin their own
Mystery which like exactly like I don't
no one wants to it's like it's like
interviewing a magician when they come
off stage EXA I can understand that it's
fun to try and guess how they did the
trick but I also don't begrudge them for
not wanting to talk about it why would
you want to ruin some of the mystery I
was like I I didn't never even thought
they would say yes totally understand
they said no um but the person who has
been let go sort of technically
resignation uh is the unity
CEO um after this entire debacle people
work calling for him to resign and he
did uh it's John rello I think is how
you I looked this up because I heard
three different pronunciations of this
of this name on different things today
it's apparently it's John rello and the
reason I I believe in that is that is
how he was introduced at a Unity
conference on a pre-recorded
intro and I therefore knowing how much
how many rehearsals happened like if
that's great sourcing work M yeah good
job it's probably that I just I saw I
can't remember which Youtuber I saw do
it this morning where they were where
they pronounced it like richo or
something that's something and I was
just like that doesn't yeah I need to
double check that before knowing that we
were going to probably talk
about apparently but then remember when
EES came out and said it where the game
was called Star Wars
Outlook not Star Wars Outlaws the cc3 so
I do remember that presid of the company
yeah wild um so he is stepping down as
CEO of unity will no longer be on its
board James wh Hurst former CEO of red
hat which is a company I'm actually not
familiar with what is Red Hat they are
they they are one of the kind of um I'm
going to have to double check what they
are but they I I believe Cloud strategy
app
development I yes yes that's that's
that's how they self- describe cool okay
we'll call that whatever not oh they're
Bas in La that never happens um so James
White host of red Hur will become
unity's interim CEO he's not like flat
out uh replacing
him um and yeah that was
announced on
Monday that he is retired from the
gaming software company after a
controversial pricing change that
frustrated numerous developers so I
think that this is like one of those
ones that had to happen you know how
sometimes like it's the literal only
option for somebody as much as used to
don't like the CEO stepping down that's
that's feels like that being a
consequence of a terrible decision that
doesn't seem as common as it used to be
maybe that's just me being an old man
about it bit doesn't feel like people I
know that football president kissed
today don't take as Sor on the the the
soccer president who kissed the female
player at the World Cup also
resigned we've had a couple it took him
a while though that was that was like he
was he was really try to stay at that
job for a while oh he and his mom chimed
in they got quotes from his mom which I
thought was the funniest part that his
mom was like how dare you tell him to
reside can't be a sexist if you've got a
mother know I know
women at least one some of the people
I've met were
wom um but yes CEO of Red Hat is
becoming the uh interim CEO so do you
know what other updates we've had uh
this is the one that's made the biggest
news and that Unity is sure that they
will have there was the there was there
was the walk back so after we did our
recording they they did a partial walk
back um which actually kind of confused
matters a bit more and then there was a
a a proper walk back you know about I
think it was a about a week later they
kind of kept teasing that they were
going to say something and then they did
and basically they walked it back to um
I think what basically me and Ramy were
both kind of saying on the on the
episode which makes us look preent of
like just do a just do a royalty just do
a cut like epic and and do that uh with
with a decent kind of Baseline starting
point there's definitely The Conspiracy
Theory version of this which is oh well
you announc the very very controversial
thing so you can pull it back to the
slightly less controversial thing um I
don't it doesn't strike me that there
was that level of thinking it's too
stupid like it was too stupid burned
them too badly I think for it to have
been in any way a smart strategy if that
was the Tactical Str if that was the
strategy they were going going for then
it was a bad strategy either way
possible but terrible so basically yeah
winding it back to something that exists
On a par with the Epic approach the big
difference with epic is that there's
still an upfront payment as well as a
royalty so I have to pay per seat for my
employees who are using Unity for us to
develop a game and then I also need to
pay royalty with epic with with the
Unreal Engine you don't pay up from you
you don't have to pay up from got for
for the seats it's it's when you start
making money so that's the that's the
difference but then um I think epic
basically have started making gestures
that that might not be how things are
for them forever um they would they
definitely they're they're putting some
some charges for now it's not on the
games teams but uh you know film um
automotive industry uses a lot of unreal
tech for producing demos and stuff um
all of that's starting to get LED on
like a per seed basis now which it
wasn't before essentially if you were an
automotive company you've been using
Unreal for free for quite some
time and as we see more and more films
start to use it for virtual production
which is coming and will be a big
seismic shift in movie making
um that's you know that that's also
something monetizing use unreal I think
it does uh Poss
Poss even on screen
that would make sense like for any kind
of for Real Time 3D rendering epic would
like you to use unreal for sure um and
yeah I think the the film side of it we
we've just seen the the um the volume
the stuff sorry that's what I meant when
I said the don't yeah the volume Oh I
thought you meant the one in Vegas which
I don't know if that uses real time it
might I I don't I know the creepy eye
video that's the seen of it um yeah no
the the the volume use is unreal but I
think that's some of the stuff that's
coming is is even more impressive than
what you've seen with the Mandalorian so
I think there's I think there's there's
cool there's cool stuff there and it
makes sense that epic want to monetize
that but that could also turn into per
seat kind of Licensing for developers
potentially they've not said that though
so put words in their mouth but like
there's going to be there's an
interesting kind of trend happening here
where uh Unity definitely needed to
monetize better and uh uh Tim Sweeney uh
has publicly said that that the Unreal
Engine needs to monetize better as well
so there's definitely like an a desire
for them to to up their prices that
they're charging
Developers for better or worse I think I
don't think this is going away it's
going to kind of increment hopefully
competition will exist I mean that's
ultimately the thing that will you know
keep the prices in a reasonable place
for those of us who use these services
true at least they still have each other
um and that's probably part of like all
the back he system yeah that Unity faced
was that unreal was a direct comparison
and and had a more appealing option um
especially in light of people feeling so
positively about uh
u5 um but yeah wants a monopoly no one I
to be fair most of the rank and fall
working at the engine companies don't
want a monopoly either like everyone
everyone benefits from a healthy
Marketplace for for any products go so I
found the open letter excuse me um sorry
if anyone has already listened to this
um I had not read it but even though
this is two weeks old at want to start
with this I'm
sorry yeah uh we should have spoken with
more of you not the problem and we
should have Incorporated more of your
feedback before announcing our new
runtime fee policy our goal with this
policy is to ensure we can continue to
support you today and tomorrow didn't
come across that way and keep deeply
investing in our game engine you are
what makes Unity great and we know we
need to listen and work hard to earn
your trust yeah okay um so the personal
plan we remain free and there will be no
runtime fee for Games built on Unity
personal we will be increasing the cap
from 100,000 to 200,000 and we will
remove the requirement to use the made
with unity splash screen that's an
interesting that's wild that's an
acknowledgement given that we talked
about that at what point is your
reputation that you are offering as a
benefit to your customers they don't
have to be publicly associated with you
that is that is an interesting true
that's interesting that's fascinating I
I found that one particularly intriguing
I uh yeah why do you think they've done
it because they know what most
developers know which is if your game
starts with a splash screen that says
made with unity there is a
large will assume you're making a bad
game yeah it's it's for for a while it's
been um it's been well we talked about
this on the show like the so Unity
personal is kind of the the kind of the
Casual hobbyist version and then when
you go to Unity Pro licensing you you
get rid of the splash screen that's one
of the main benefits of going pro is
that you lose the splash screen um so
it's they it's been the case for a while
but the fact that they're now removing
that um such a weirdo personal as well
is yeah oh God close y it's such a weird
choice to have it that way at all it's
so funny to be like the free one you get
this screen which means you can make
whatever crap you want really like it's
just such a strange it's a
self-fulfilling kind of Prophecy it's
it's one of those things that just I'm
sure it made sense before they did it
that's all off in the way and I guess at
that point they kind of locked in um but
yeah fair enough a lot of things make
sense before we do them uh no game with
less than a million in trailing 12 month
Revenue will be subject to the fee and
for creators on Unity Pro and unity
Enterprise are also making changes based
on feedback the runtime fee policy will
only apply beginning the next LTS
version of unity shipping 2024 and
Beyond it's preferable do you want me do
do do our audience know what an LTS is
oh I don't know audience do you know
what an LTS is oh I know what an LTS is
I'm saying do we want to explain it to
them yeah go
ahead
uh so basically that is longterm support
so basically when long longterm support
not longterm longterm support be amazing
it's basically when when an engine's
being worked on it's like any any
software you would update you get
patches things are constantly in flux
when you're developing a game
professionally and you want to sell that
game you want stability more than you
want new features so what happens is
when a when an engine hits a certain
Milestone they lock it in and they say
we're not adding anything to this we're
just going to keep bug fixing this build
for the I think it's I think with unity
it's a two-year window off the top of my
head I think that's right so basically
if you're developing a game and you know
your game's coming out in less than two
years you're like okay we are locking
into this we're not going to use any of
the fancy new features we're going to
make sure that our game is as stable as
we can get it on an engine level because
we can fix our bugs but it's much harder
to fix bugs in the engine yeah so it's
LTS is most professional games teams
that are at you know less than two years
away from release or just frankly a lot
of Studios just generally have this as
policy will only use the LTS so when I'm
building stuff I'm building stuff in an
end version of the engine that is one or
two years older than M features that are
being announced because I need that
stability LTS is like a whole software
development industry thing right that's
not just a games thing yeah yeah I
assume so I obviously I only I only know
how to make games so I only know in the
games context but yeah I bet it is I
think it's anything in software
development where it's like this is
stable effectively though I also know
LTS is a security company um
unrelated so the runtime fee policy will
only apply beginning with the next LTS
version of unity which ships in 2024
your games that are currently shipped
and the projects that you are currently
working on will not be included which
yay uh we will make sure that you can St
you upgrade them which is which that's
true I did just skip over that specific
phrasing unless you upgrade console if
you want to support any theoretical
consoles that might come out ever which
I assume there I don't it's a massive
leak to say they're probably will be
more future consoles that are not yet
current I think that's fair enough yeah
then I think we can say that I think
we're legally allowed to say that um
then you're going to have to need to
update so Thomas Was Alone if it comes
to ps6 down the road oh hey atin need to
be in a new version of you hey Austin
how you doing I don't think I was ready
for a Mike bthl Proper
stash you know I didn't even notice
until people mention it on the comments
I was like yeah he does have a
mustache I'm I'm I'm on the fence it is
is is split is dividing a nation this
mustache like I have was this here last
time and because I missed it I didn't
see it and I'm just this is old news I
think I was I think I was halfway here
on sopia I've slowly basically built up
confidence and pulled everything back
you know there a grade five then a grade
sorry 5 millimet then four millimeter
then three I've like slowly receded the
rest of it so it was here for St it's
interesting look to have the
stubble with the rest and then the
mustach like it's not clean shaving
whowhere else has a way to really make
the mustache a thing that you're
standing by it's it it kind of it's
casual it's like I'm not fully sure
about this it's uh it's the Henry C a
casual mustache yeah you could cast me a
Superman right now you cause a massive
project problem that's not true we can
effortlessly and perfectly CG it out if
no one will ever know no one will ever
know it be SE how would they know what
uh am I interrupting here uh we're
talking about uh Unity firing their CEO
and the the brief update uh from the
open letter on the runtime fee which yes
uh if you I saw that I saw that he was
leaving I didn't I didn't know anything
this is a few weeks old we just wanted
to issue an update because we spoke
about it at length really but the story
yeah your games that are
oh I was just sending that to Austin yes
your games that are currently shipped
and the projects you're currently work
on will not be included unless you
choose to upgrade them to the new
version new version of unity we'll make
sure that you can stay on the terms
applicable for the version Unity editor
you are using and then for games that
are subject to the runtime for you we
giving you a choice of either a 2.5%
Revenue share or the calculated amount
based on the number of new people
engaging with your game each month which
makes sense both these number are
self-reported from data you already have
available so did they just like
completely walk back the install thing
and go actually right we don't know how
to do that I think you'll find Al L that
they never said that they had a secret
magical tool that would track you
who said that no one said that don't
worry about it they definitely don't
have that they they they publicly
basically said there was a massive
misunderstanding all of us developers
who saw those tweets just we confused
fine we were confused yes how does the
self-reporting
like is there any version of that that's
not just them basically
saying please just give us some money
from your earnings like how is that not
play that way is there any version of
auditing or something that they would
theoretically have a right to as part of
the contract so it's they kind of
speaking past some of the developers
there so so there are
platforms notably mobile where there are
engagement stats that you could
reference so things so M so basically
unique users per month would be a metric
on like apple could report that
independent of the developer like from
for an iOS game I mean they they could
but also like you can go onto the apple
back end and see that information
yourself as a developer where where we
were where the me and ramies of this
world were getting worried was on PC you
can't do that on Console it's harder to
do that um so they're not really coming
at us with that that is them they they
want to go after mobile deers they want
the money from the mobile deers because
frankly they're making much more money
than we are we are we're not relevant I
mean most Indie developers probably fall
under that 1 million um a year threshold
anyway um those us who don't you know
we'll just do the 2.5 because it's half
of the the Epic rate like it it's it
makes they sat down and they they
figured this out to be basically not
that worrying to this the developers and
I think that's ultimately the react
what's been the reaction to all of this
is sure that seems fine we're a little
worried you might try and do this again
you know there's a little bit of concern
of of a bit of lack of trust there and
and I I ime that's one of the reasons
that there's one less employee Unity
today is then trying to rebuild that
that
relationship do you think that that is
that was the big discussion
Point um before uh like when we when we
were chatting with Ramy about all this
um the question of why would we trust
them again I get that there's a
dependency and so you're in certain
cases almost forced to trust them again
or
you have to trust someone like that's
you you either well you trust someone or
you build your own engine um or you use
open source but there's different layers
of trust and and reliability built into
that basically there is no perfect
solution but there never was In fairness
I think I think it was shocking the
degree to which Unity swung in a
direction that no one was expecting But
ultimately companies are gonna companies
are gonna company like there's they were
trying to get mobile games for sure
didn't consider everybody else and yeah
I think
you're we are as well you know the fact
that we were that we did kick up a fuss
about it I think I think I think without
the massive backlash that might not have
gone that way I just saw a tweet that
asman gold replied to who's a twitch
streamer and he replied and was like
yeah this apology isn't going to work
because people aren't going to something
like aren't going to roll over like
whining Gamers like he like the game
devs are the ones that are like not
going to let this go and it's like well
yeah because it's these people's lives
like they're not going to let it go it's
not going to be forgiven no way but I
think I think you're already nailed at
Austin that it's it's the dependency you
don't have a choice really but to try
and trust him again it's like it's like
it's like how no one wants a landlord
either but you know you roof above your
head right so it's so and and mortgages
and and buying houses is a a trickier
thing for people to get into I think
there's I think there's a the the thing
that's fascinating with this in the way
this particular apology is written is it
does feel exactly like it's written for
consumers rather than partners
it doesn't feel I don't feel like you
know you know as a developer you you get
to know Unity you've got you know
representatives from Unity that you you
have conversations with you go to events
near well we were the three of us were
at an event sponsored by unity at Dice
and I I end up going in up up to VIP and
having like a little meeting up there
during mid party which felt very silly
but like that that's how I interact I'm
used to interacting with unity as kind
of as a partner as a business partner
you know we we have a relationship and
this reads like a dear
consumers uh cyber Punk's going to be
delayed by six months and that's a
different relationship and it felt a bit
weird um did you have if you'd be
willing to answer the question even Mike
did you have any talks with unity like
privately while this was going down did
they reach out to people like you they
did reach out um I didn't initially
interact as I and I said as much to them
privately like your boss is going to
walk this back in a few days this is
silly um we'll talk then and then it
kind of dragged on and yeah we did we
I've not spoken to my representative
there yet but they did reach out so like
I'm curious how many they tried to talk
to privately as well because that's what
they should do yeah but that was that
was the The Reach Out happened right at
the start after that initial very
strange announcement so yeah I I think I
think this was followed up by a
firesight chat which went badly in a few
different ways as well oh did it I
didn't know that I did I saw the link
out to the fire side chat just a couple
of a couple of uh ill Force out
statements I can't actually remember the
details off the top of my head but I
remember it not going I remember some
dead acting but basically I think
ultimately at this stage developers have
they're either onto another engine or
they're they're going to accept it or I
think a lot of developers are just
looking at their options just seeing
what other engines are out there
exploring possibilities I me that's why
I was curious about the like how much
we're forced to accept it because like
we meaning like an indie Dev uh
is forced to accept it um and how much
they're rolling the dice on it being
just such a pain in the ass it's like
it's like um it's like switching utility
providers uh where in many cases you're
really only option if you really don't
like you know AT&T or whatever in a
given area this true with lots of areas
of the US your choice would be to move
um and it's sort of my parents didn't
believe me when I told them that I
couldn't change my is they were like
just go to the other one I was like it
doesn't work that way in the US it's
wild it's so wild it's so wild the lack
of competition is is weird it's it's an
odd it's well it's one of those where
the notion of a utility being a kind of
public good uh a sort of cost a sort of
quality of life Baseline thing I can
understand the logic behind trying to
file that separately but you end up with
a situation where you're like hey my
phone company really sucks and that's
apparently just the end of the sentence
and the end of all with respect it
doesn't sound very American that's the
thing that gets me is like you guys are
all about like competition driving down
prices and blah blah blah like and it
seems it seems weirdly in the other
other direction it's a strangely I think
it's pretty is sort of unique to that
that specific example isn't it Austin I
don't think there are many other things
that well power Power
Water um I mean the anything that is
anything that's
consider yeah utility is consider I'm
not an expert on this I'm sure I will be
Tak to as well although I think that's
shifting now cell phones on cellon on
anymore yeah you can swap be fine
there's definitely a lot of competitive
you know Verizon versus Sprint versus
AT&T versus so I don't think that but
but um but internet service providers
you know like I think I have literally
one option here at the studio um and and
same same thing I think there were two I
think I at home I I think I actually
have two
options um uh and that's sort of rare
like oo spoiled for choice and um uh and
I don't know I don't under I don't
understand the kind of
underlying um reasoning for why
sometimes it's these sort of these sort
of uh permitted monopolies I mean we
have Anti-Trust laws that would
theoretically make that illegal but
utilities classified as a different type
of business it's got to be like
grandfathered in or something right it's
got to be something in the history of
how those things were set up my
understanding is that they are
considered a thing that that um um is
sort of in the same way that we don't
have this is a this is a bad analogy
because one is sort of circuitously an
actual government employee but we don't
have competitive fire departments we
don't have competitive police
departments you can hire private
security you can hire private uh
firefighters you know like the people in
Malibu in places where there's a lot of
fires they often have literal private
fire departments but they're not they
are not they don't they don't have like
an
authority separately or somehow
superseding the local police department
for example um and so it's like the
train of thought that says we should
probably just have one Police Department
that you know is a is sort of a
guaranteed service the the line of
thinking I believe is sort of the
extension to how you get to people need
to have access to water uh you know to
be able to tap into a city water supply
you need to be able to tap into the
electrical grid those need to have
similarly a kind of that's the thinking
you do end up with this situation though
where it's like you know hey my power's
out you call there's no the number
doesn't go anywhere it's not like you
and everybody knows if I go well I'll
just email the power company it's like
yeah good luck with that that's an
incredibly naive that just came out so
it's like there are there are you know
seemingly consequences and I'm not
necessarily saying that it it there
should be like 50 power companies all
vying for it I don't know the solution
to that but I do believe that is the the
reasoning why be nice to have a is it's
it's not that would be nice but it's it
what's weird about it for me so we used
to so the same was true in the UK we had
um uh the Tories basically kind of
privatized the law of services so it
used to be when I was I was very young
there was like br Bri gas and one water
company and one but the the thing that
I'm surprised by in situations where
there is that kind of Monopoly you can't
vote right there's no democracy to this
you can't you there's no a politician
can't run on a platform of I'm G to make
Power they may have
previously well yeah I know that's a
huge thing in the UK they may have
previously had it be like what are they
called when you get to vote for like a
certain proposition Austin a referendum
are those referendums well I'm not sure
sure I need more context to know what
you're asking you know how like I can't
vote in this country yeah I do yeah like
when you know how you can like when you
vote so when you vote in Australia you
just vote for a representative that's
really it you don't vote on an issue
whereas in the US you can vote on an
issue so maybe that at some point like
it was voted for the government doesn't
set the prices for the power company
presum no that's independent so you kind
of have no you don't you don't have a
vote and you don't and you can't vote
this is so off track but I love it lapw
DWP yeah is I imagine who you're Water
and Power also with yeah which that is
that is a government that is government
right that's what I was going to say we
live in LA services use well I think
that the whole of La is the lwp which is
just Los Angeles Department of Water and
Power um yeah that is
government right like that's the yeah I
guess in that case um that's interesting
interesting I hadn't really thought
utility company yeah that there would be
private and public utilities cuz part of
the whole part of the whole uh
conversation
around um I'm suddenly blanking on what
it was called but the the whole notion
of if the internet as a whole ought to
be sort of legis or uh officially
recognized as a utility or not u c that
that centered around uh I'm drawing such
a blank uh and I I know I know that I
know the comments will reflect the blank
I am drawing
um damn Austin I forg draw blanks again
the the comments always hate you Austin
they really annoy dra those blanks you
draw all the time yeah yeah doesn't know
every reference to everything ever
Austin blankley that's what I
[Laughter]
co well done well done thank you thank
you not not well done to me well done to
the comment yes as in side um I found
some quotes from the fireside chat that
said the paper as an aside you mean the
actual subject yeah as an as as a on
track to aride the paper install plan
was a way for Unity to decide the
software is valued of the most high
performing games that use it uh which
makes sense Pokémon go whatever paying
the calculated amount would be better
for top developers than Unity taking a
2.5% off the top and I guess it makes
sense if they were just thinking about
the mega mega mega mega Rich to go
actually the deal is better for you if
you if we charge fire install rather
than via yeah the percentage um it's
just obviously so shortsighted because
why would you think about the top
companies El well I like I said like I
said last time on this like I get it if
they don't give a [__] of our Indies
that's totally reasonable we don't make
them much money we're we're we're
financially I would like them to care
but I also don't I don't it doesn't it's
not a mystery to me that they wouldn't
what's weird though is every free
to-play game is a failure until it's not
right that original plan as pitch they
needed you were kind of if you want to
incentivize people to experiment and
make the next Pokemon go right so like
you would like people to succeed in
theory you'll just be attractive enough
to try like it's it's it's not you know
the yeah it's it's it's it's a weird it
was a weird thing with that initial one
but I think this new one kind of
resolves a lot of that stuff so
ultimately I think there's I've not seen
many developers criticize the substance
of what's being suggested here what I
have seen is a lot of developers you
know worry not trusting that it won't go
up by 2% next year you know that's the
thing that you never could have trusted
that anyway though really right exactly
and I think that's the that's the that's
the been silly to ever have have thought
that the reason I was uh bringing up the
whole the the what Goddess on to the
whole utilities versus not uh concept
was the idea that it is when I said you
know if I want a new phone company I
would have to move I would imagine that
for a lot of Indie developers even if
this economically represents probably a
tiny overall percentage of their revenue
I would imagine it's a huge number of
actual developers that the cost of of
starting over um and and also set never
mind the whole retroactive thing of
shipped games and that whole absurdity
but just even just I'm about to ship a
game or I'm I'm in the early days of
preparing to you know spin up a
studio um and now we're spooked about
Unity but you know if this like like you
mentioned I remember in the in the
previous chat that you know people are
hired on the basis of their fluency with
given tools that they are expected to
use with their job you know you wouldn't
hire if you're planning on shipping a
game in unity you're not going to hire
someone that Brands thems a a yeah an
unreal expert because that's just not
what you're doing I have yeah no and
you're seeing it across I've got several
people I work with who are spending
their weekends just pottering with new
engines I because because people are
people are thinking forward to this I
think I don't think there's the you
should always do anyway eggs
basket yeah but expertise requires Focus
as well you can't put your egg you can't
put eggs in every basket because you'll
have egg in every basket and you'll
never have enough eggs The metall Falls
AP po you know what I'm saying like
there's I don't have that many baskets I
only have so
many and and so and so few years of life
to actually fill any Baskets at all and
I think that's I don't think I have I
don't think I own a single basket I do
have cartons of eggs do any do either of
you own a
basket a wash like a laundry basket that
doesn't count that's for laundry not
eggs I don't think people
have any container can contain eggs I
will I will this is a that's correct
you're you're in a semantic mindfield
hit the no I think that's an interes not
only do I have no baskets I have cartons
and I and I would never not put all my
eggs in one carton a moment of you're
right I would always put all of my eggs
in one cotton by reminds me this reminds
me of this reminds me of the Demitri
Martin bit where he goes um there's the
expression ever throw stones in glass
houses and he goes how about just don't
be a dick and don't throw stones unless
you were trapped in a glass house and
all you had was St in which case that's
a great place to throw stones yeah which
means really the only time you should
throw stones is when you're in glass
houses and
stuck that's very I was I was like you
know the question it's GNA cost a it's
GNA cost a lot for any developer who
seriously wants to move over yeah that's
you're putting you basically multiply
your burn rate cannot imagine many
people by six months just to retrain
it's it's it's a big thing but also
developers individually I know lots of
developers who are looking at the
situation going I have put my eggs in
one basket I need to go and at least be
fluent in one of the competitors just in
case this happens again that's a valid
perspective let's say that um if Unity
is making you
know $100 uh a given unit of Revenue a
$100 unit
um and I don't have any clue what the
stats are but just based on Broad Trends
I would think that you know certainly
more than 50% of that is the mobile
market probably much more than 50 much
more so let's say it's 85 I'm making
that up but let's just say it's 85 and
that the the the entirety of the 15
remaining is all the rest of the game
industry whatever Indie Studios or
midlevel like double a kind of or
whoever that that means and then like
what you know whatever kind of
additional in the same way that like
movie studios will use unreal to do uh
to do uh previs on their shots and that
I imagine there's uses like that for
Unity outside normal industry that's
sort part of this miscellaneous grab
back so when you said they may have
underestimated how loud and
outspoken members of that 15% would be
does that mean let's say that that
wasn't just culturally a thing let's say
all Indie Debs were were you know keep
my head down go along to get along don't
make waves I'm not going to Tweet about
it it's it's I'm sure it'll get solved
somehow I you know whatever if that was
the prevailing attitude does that mean
that the 85% of mobile developers were
not equally riled up uh or like would
they have is there a world where this
was a business model where they said
okay fair no they were red up but they
were red up in private theyed up some of
them maybe weren't because like for
again I keep using Pokémon go as an
example for Pokémon go it probably would
be a negative if they took
2.5% Revenue versus charging for
installs because the yes play amount of
players who installed that game and then
spend a ton of money like it's
beneficial for them to only be charged
on that install and not for all the
Realties of if you're if you're moob if
you're a successful mobile game you're
already spending in I don't know what
the number is but an amount of money on
user acquisition anyway so you have an
assumption that every install is going
to cost you I think some of the numbers
I've seen are in dollars so like two
three dollars to acquire a user to do an
ads to get someone in the door so adding
20 cents to that for the engine yeah
it's not it's it's it's a it's a line on
a balance sheet it's not a massive
impact I but I think the other thing
that I think old Unity got and new Unity
didn't get and I think I'm hoping
they'll move towards is that 85% to use
your numbers
Austin where are they recruiting from
and where did they all start in the 15%
you know the only reason I'm you know uh
making games and have a bigger team and
do my thing is because someone at Unity
invited me to an event when I was one
dude [__] around on my computer and I
went because there was free beer in it
like and that's the that's the angle
that kind of gets you start
time was exactly it would work today if
they did the same but like but that's
but every for every mobile Studio that's
every Pokemon go if you walk around the
offices of Pokemon go first of all the
company
started as an indie Studio many years
ago making small things but then
everyone who works there they started
using unity in in uni they used Unity
when they were making inde games they've
done whatever you have to serve everyone
across that pipeline L because that's
where the skill set's coming from that's
why so many Indie Games I I can't
remember that Ramy gave a percentage but
a majority of indie games are made in
unity rather than real means that
universities pay attention to that and
they're start they're training their
students in whichever engine they think
is going to most viably get them a job
this stuff works its way through the
system completely so you have to be
looking after the little guys and the
big guys and I that's where they where
they tripped here and I I I'm sure
they're going to now work very very hard
I'm expecting a lot of you know events
you know F focused on students that are
you know sponsored by unity they're kind
of pushing this stuff trying to get
credit back because if you're a gamer
who's like you know you're 14 15 year
old you're into really into video games
you're thinking you might want to like
learn how to do that and maybe do that
as a job and you're watching all of the
your favorite YouTubers covering this
story you're installing unreal you're
not installing Unity true and that's a
problem for all of us about 10 years
from now using Unity so there's there's
just a whole there's a whole ecosystem I
think it's very easy to focus on the
profits of the big company but to forget
where that big company came from and to
think long term about where it's like
it's like uh birth rate replacement
rates or something you know it's it's
one of those where it it won't it won't
bite you in the ass today but uh a
generation later you'll have a very
different landscape the kids making the
next month us you need to make sure
they're using Unity the thing I haven't
even thought about you're right yeah cuz
somewhere someone is somewhere someone
is and none of us have heard of them and
they're watching YouTubers take the piss
out of unity because of this story and
they maybe installing unreal instead
I've already said that but that that's
that's the real danger here um but I I
think that's what they're going to build
the youths the youths are the danger
it's just it's very we're very focused
as an
industry what oh yeah I messed it up
it's fine it'll get better um i' I've
been taking off for these calls I
realized that I didn't take it off this
time um yeah it's it's it's getting
there um but yeah no it's uh it's a it's
a I I think this is I think they're
making steps in the right direction and
I'm I'm hopeful that we did exactly what
I think they did exactly what uh the in
the discussion we have with Ramy what we
expected them to do the issues remain
exactly the same which is like yeah they
can update their TOS at any time um but
I don't
feel as negatively about that in that
every company can and does you know uh
that's not exclusive to Unity they'd be
very dumb to do it anytime soon um to go
back to any of these changes though I do
keep remembering they didn't they delete
the public terms of service update and
then they tweeted and they were like
you're all misrepresenting why we did
that we just deleted it because it
didn't have many views which is like
that's not been addressed or corrected
what an insane thing to do and say that
they haven't mentioned that would be the
next thing that they in my opinion that
they should do if anyone for is watching
this I think the next thing to do is to
actually explain some of those
incredibly ever delete weird choices
it's so
strange um but yeah that that stuff goes
on that that stuff is the stuff that
because to be clear you should never
trust a company to not change its terms
of service course but
trust because because anyone can do it
trust is about the the inro space you
can't stop a partner from cheating on
you but trust means you're making an
assumption that that person is going to
to not yeah effectively Unity cheated on
all of us and uh here we are just hoping
that Unity changes you don't trust
people to not do things that are legally
they're blocked from doing because they
were not going to do that but trust is
in this gray area anyway so it's it's I
the analogy is falling apart but like
it's it's it's this it's this thing of
like yeah you have just shown yourself
to be somewhat less trustworthy than we
all thought you were so now you got to
you know buy flowers yeah what was the
um has there been any discussion or
illumination I've I've I've done zero
research on the specific legal aspect of
it to that point
of you know there was the Privacy
concern aspect but if they walk back the
whole they walked it back it seems
becomes a non-issue yeah but it's still
a very strange non-issue like they see
to have just forgotten a communication
issue rather than a legal issue but was
there ever a legal issue behind the idea
of retroactively charging people for a
thing that they didn't sign for you know
like because you're right you do
companies will change I I get emails all
the time from every manufacturer of
every plugin I use every piece of
software there's been an update in our
terms of Serv you know there's a whole
South Park episode about this you can
Decline and then just not use it anymore
it won't retroactively charge you for
the way that it used to be but also
realistically you you don't you don't
read those because they're usually
they're 99% of the time they are
microscopic little changes or they are
we've added a sentence because this
country passed this one law so we need
to include this one sentence now that
reflects that if you're in Italy then
now this is true for you specifically
that like there's a lot of even the US
has different states will have potential
uh different governing rules where
you'll say like the following does not
apply in Delaware and or whatever like
there are certain things like that that
what I imagine most of those terms of
service that you just kind of mindlessly
go along with are but I'm curious that
it didn't strike me as
legal um to Bill people for a thing that
they did not initial like for a product
released uh and okay yeah if they're not
going to do that anymore it's all a moot
point but I just it it struck me as
trust aside what was the their
plan for implementing that is there any
legal record I remember this was at the
heart of the I mean as a citizen of
America you're allowed to ask that
question in
public I just remember I remember when
all the all the
um uh crap went down regarding Doom
Eternal and the soundtrack and all that
a big part of
IDs argument specifically was that they
had promised a collector's addition that
would include a soundtrack album and
that consumer protection laws in certain
territories and for some reason
Australia sticks out I remember as one
of them in particular said that if they
if someone pre-ordered that and doesn't
come with that they're now in a position
of liability that is highly not worth it
for them um and so they were that was my
understanding is a big part of their now
obviously there's there's a whole lot to
that story I don't want to reopen that
that thing but I just remember
thinking certain territories have those
kinds of consumer protection laws and I
would imagine this This falls under
something along those lines where you
know as a as a as a user of that
software in the
UK you know that their ability to
retroactively charge you for a thing you
didn't sign for just strikes me
as
um I I just don't see how there isn't a
legal recourse for that I guess I guess
it's I share your interest but lack the
knowledge to uh have an opinion on yeah
fair enough the the by the way I I I was
Googling to to refresh my memory it was
the discussion on the FCC policy of net
neutrality in the US and the idea that
internet service providers are
essentially required to be uh not pay
for pay for Speed as much as possible
and by resending net neutrality they can
supposedly create internet Fast Lanes
versus slow Lanes punish you for using a
rival streaming service yeah things like
uh service the article mentions things
like um certain providers uh throttling
specific apps like Skype uh in order to
incentivize you to use their version
that kind of thing blah blah blah that
was the argument that was what I was
trying to remember it was the phrase net
neutrality which was escaping me that
term the argument was if you declare the
internet a public utility that whole
problem basically goes away because then
uh they're required to treat everybody
equally in in theory um interestingly um
net
neutrality did not we don't have what
that was aspiring to the internet was
not declared a public utility and in
general it does not seem that the
apocalypse has beset us all I would be
curious if there are case studies of the
kinds of things people were worried
about I don't know there may there may
be but it is interesting that it's been
a number of years now I had kind of
forgotten about the whole thing um yeah
I feel like net neutrality hasn't been
spoken about in a while like I remember
that being thing school maybe they'll
slowly but
surely I would I would also think so
they will slowly boil that FR yeah which
I guess like
is ification it's that kind of idea that
all services will inevitably get a bit
worse yeah um because we'll let them yep
basically well or we don't have a choice
or we don't have a choice um I have to
get back to work but I did want to say
Austin congratulations on uh a a
birthday huge congrats on that and B on
really hard for that yeah I thought um
on Australian game of the year for stray
Gods I'd like to point out that you're
wishing me a happy birthday one month
and one day after my birthday thank I
think it was the last time that we had
spoken so you take what you can get all
right that's true well happy birthday to
you put it in the bank for whenever that
circles around next you know what Mike
likewise we do have I won't accept I
will not accept a birthday in the bank
uh that really soon so November 7th
that's right you're
Scorpio we are closer to my birthday
then to your why is that always the
reaction always I'm not a star sign
person but I Rahul will mention anyone
who was a Scorpio to me at any
opportunity so I know that you're a
Scorpio because Scorpio because Rahul
has told me that you are and so thus I
should have been like oh of course it's
around November I think we're
discovering that the two of you have
dinner conversations at length about the
what's the joke astrological signs of
people you know so is this is does he
just constantly reference our
relationship is
in Reverse in many a way where I'll send
him like couple memes and he's always
the wife um and in the case of astrology
is the same thing where he's like into
astrology uh and I am not and so he's
always like Scorpio because he's a
Scorpio oh I see apparently you're a
bunch of bad very much like being being
R
yeah the only the only on the only thing
I've ever been able to GS I don't know
astrology at all I know lots of people
who who who do who do believe in in
aspects of it all I've been able to work
out is Scorpios bit shitty that's
basically I think that's but isn't that
true for all of them isn't all of that
like everything no no the rest are brave
bold suppor but I feel like every bad
thing that happens someone will look up
and go that's such a Virgo thing that's
such a scor viros and Virgos are known
for being
perfectionists are overly
critical um I don't
remember very tidy which I don't know
about that Austin I heard about your
your toilet there was not a Virgo move
you needed a TR hey the toilet itself
was clean the toilet itself was clean it
just was in disrepair that's not AO move
is all I'm saying it had moving parts
that weren't supposed to be moving Parts
uh but you probably are a perfectionist
maybe I am a perfectionist but I will I
will I I for sure but I I have I will
will acknowledge that I have um that I
have uh I'm not I'm I'm not doing the
best
uh P of trash in this room right now
literally a whole pile of trash next to
me because I got back into Pokemon
cards
um you can see there's there's my
there's several weeks of mail which is
all
entirely uh it's that time of year where
please don't hold up any mail to the
camera I get thousands I'm trying to
find a representative example that's not
don't hold up a letter to the don't do
no this one's good because I these are
friends of mine but I got the back of
the please stop doing it's dress on it I
get lots and lots of these every year uh
uh just anyone who's in
the oh because you're a Grammy
voter hila is a friend of mine uh uh
yeah your audio went Weir stopped
recording yeah weird oh really for a sec
you heard it too as well yeah you
disappeared for a second well from this
point forward your audio is in your
OBS all right well on that note we
should thanks for the congrats yes
congrats on Australian Game of the Year
actually is that is that um is the is
that agas is that a big thing because
this was unfamiliar to me but when I
looked at the footage there were a lot
of people there yeah I would think it's
well people in Australia so you a huh
well there any like
so they kind of cluster yeah for in
Melbourne for video games yeah no it is
a pretty big deal yeah that's that's
huge for I was super happy for
summerfall you know a new studio new IP
new new everything uh and most of them
are pretty young you know this is like a
lot of their
first Idol so yeah oh yeah um and on
that note everybody we will maybe see
you next week potentially never know
anymore who knows uh thanks for hanging
out by for sure won't be here great
bye